Oh looking pretty good
this girl is turning 30 it's coming at
me like a freight train
it's a decade where you answer life's
questions will I have kids am I ever
gonna get married and the biggest one am
I gonna get a dog someday in order to
get ready for the big three-o I
partnered with Olay to help me feel and
look my best
so we've divided these challenges into
four different episodes body heart mind
and soul so we're gonna start with the
body which is slowly working on myself
from the outside in and I just want to
introduce you to my best friend in the
office I'm gonna miss her so much
I didn't realize how dependent I am on
coffee to wake up this is a typical day
for me I am giving notes on an edit
writing up a beat sheet and proposal
shooting in the afternoon when
everything's hard like this I would just
really love a shot of espresso it's okay
it's not that big of a deal right Mike
it's not big of a deal well we'll get
through it you're gonna be fine when I'm
tired and I have to like be on camera I
feel like my face is puffy I need a
little wake-up call so I'm using this
new eye cream from Olay the eye cream
was nice it gave me another sensation to
kind of feel like okay the day is
starting now well it feels like my eyes
are having a cup of coffee coming home
and not having my sip of rosé a while I
took my bath was hard but you know I got
over it pretty quickly the part where I
started missing the alcohol was when I
went out with my friends at the end of
the week it's like you're meant to be
here drinking yes yes I do want to drink
but no I can't I cannot
I tried so very hard to get sleep last
night when I gave up coffee I kind of
expected my sleep to be perfect off the
bat I tried putting like lavender and my
oil diffuser making sure my room was
really cold hopefully I can get eight
hours after I got over that hump I
definitely slept like a baby morning I
got eight hours of sleep last night I
feel pretty good today
I didn't realize how much 64 ounces
actually is it's like 64 shots of water
after doing this challenge for about
five full days I will say my skin looks
pretty damn clear I know it's a lot of
water as they go into my 30s my
responsibilities hopefully we'll only
ramp up so I just want to make sure that
I continue to kind of work on the
foundation of Devon it's really helpful
to take away these crutches even if it's
only for 24 or 48 hours helps you take
stock of what's actually going on in
your body and to see what your body
actually needs I'm not giving up coffee
for the rest of my life I can't do that
I know myself and I love myself and I
can't do that so stick around for the
next episodes in this turning 30 series
where I'm going to take on challenges
that have to do with my heart my mind
and my soul